it's it's this cross between a concord a
rail gun and an air hockey table we'll
be able to faster than
the world's fastest bullet train i have
a name for it named for it which is
called the hyperloop
in 2013 elon musk sketched out an idea
to use magnetically levitating capsules
inside near vacuum chambers to create a
new
super fast mode of transport that could
connect la to san francisco
in around half an hour fast forward to
2021
and two companies virgin hyperloop and
hyperloop tt
are in a neck and neck race to turn the
idea into a reality
and develop the world's first commercial
hyperloop system
virgin hyperloop will be the first i
think that we are leading the race
they've both raised tens of millions of
dollars from high profile investors
with virgin founder richard branson
backing that group's project
the speed we can put these tracks these
tunnels out is
dramatic virgin has already run tests
with passengers
yes both companies have signed
agreements to potentially carry paying
passengers and goods by the end of the
decade in the u.s
and other countries but there are still
a lot of questions around safety
business models and just how the
technology can work in the real world
there's a lot of kind of things details
that need to be ironed out in order to
know really whether it revolutionized
transport so
will there be a winner in the race to
bring hyperloop into the real world
first let's take a step back hyperloop
is not a brand new concept it's actually
been around since the 17th century
russeline walker is a transport analyst
who is advising the european union and
hyperloop as it assesses the potential
of the technology
lots of different variations of it have
for one reason or another failed due to
flaws in the systems or concepts
in the early 1800s inventors were
exploring using pneumatic tubes to
transport people from point a
to point b and nowadays that principle
is being used in everyday things such as
drive-through banking
and magnetic levitation has been around
for decades
like some of the trains in china and
japan that can run at more than 350
miles an hour
but projects that combine those two
principles for
electric powered capsules that can reach
speeds of up to 760 miles an hour have
accelerated in recent years
elon musk has kind of reunited hyperloop
for the modern world
but musk said he wasn't going to build
it himself whilst he's not developing
hyperloop himself he is active in this
space so
after the launch of the white paper his
company spacex
has hosted i think up to four
competitions for hyperloop
we built a hyperloop test track adjacent
to spacex
just for a student competition it was
sort of quite quite fun to do that
but it was kind of a hobby thing as a
result of that there's been a number of
hyperloop companies that have developed
hyperloop tt was founded in california
in 2013
and says it has some 130 million dollars
in funding
today we've got more than 800
contributors in 50 companies
that are working together to develop it
andres de leon
is hyperloop tt's ceo he says the
company has created this full-scale
carriage and a test track in europe
and is teaming up with rail firms
hitachi and altran
this is the really the first time that
the transportation industry the legacy
transportation industry
is really starting to believe in the
airport you know virgin has more money
about 400 million dollars their ceo jay
walder
says not only is their test track longer
but it's also carried its first
passengers
we decided that we really needed to be
able to build physical assets and to be
able to show
what we can do we took a huge monumental
milestone step
where we saw the first people ride in a
hyperloop
i think it's a race to be able to get
this done right now and we really love
the race
some analysts say virgin has the edge
mostly because of its patents
and resources this is really based on
the facts is
probably virgin is ahead of the grain
and they've got the money for the r
d so it kind of feels like they will
they are winning the race but who knows
the next big goal for both virgin and
hyperloop tt
is to build six mile long test tracks by
2025.
we want to break ground uh in in west
virginia soon to be able to
to do that we hope to have the
commercial prototype in abu dhabi
up and running in two and a half three
years governments
including the uae and europe have
evaluated the feasibility of hyperloop
projects
and both companies have studied how they
could connect us cities less than 900
miles apart
like kansas city and st louis or
chicago and pittsburgh the department of
transportation said
some hyperloop projects could be
eligible for federal grants
we're working toward the certification
of this technology
uh by by 2025 and that gives us the
ability
to go forward not as
technology but as a transportation
system but
before you can run hyperloops across the
u.s you would need to get permission to
build huge infrastructure
which could meet resistance even elon
musk has run into problems he's invested
in a company called the boring company
which is
an infrastructure and tunneling company
focusing on trying to reduce the cost of
tunnelling
when the boring company planned to dig
tunnels under los angeles in 2018 to
reduce
traffic it was sued by locals and had to
build another tunnel in a different part
of the city
similar tunnels could also be used by
hyperloops
you can picture then a hyperloop in a
tunnel
running quite quite long distances
exactly hyperloop companies also have to
figure out passenger safety and business
models
the major risk is around you know having
vehicles traveling at
speeds faster than any other public
transport mode we've ever had before
operating at very short intervals to
each other inside breaking distance
in a very unhospitable environment so as
the if there's an
incident you know you're enclosed in a
vacuum tube which is
not ideal for breathing experts worry
sudden acceleration to such a high speed
in a windowless chamber
could also make passengers sick the cost
of hyperloop travel could also be too
high for most people
and if terminals had to be built on the
outskirts of cities
the whole system would be less efficient
by the time you've transited to those
um hybrid terminals and gone through
security checks etc etc
then that undermines the speed advantage
that you've got
addressing these concerns hyperloop tt
and virgin hyperloop have both said
they've developed systems to keep people
safe
but the first hyperloops may not be
carrying passengers at all
our future ports will integrate
hyperloop technology for synchronized
seamless intelligent movement of cargo
freight will absolutely be
the first type of hyperloop system i
think on the market
and it's not necessarily the biggest
benefit but it's a way of testing the
concept and getting people used to it
without having that passenger risk
involved as to who will win between
virgin and hyperloop tt
for now both companies are benefiting
from the hype
you're seeing hyperloop as an industry
this is hyperloop with it with a
small h it's the way we think about the
word train
for example and and i think that's great
this shouldn't be
just about one company it should be
about building an industry
i think that there is a space for two
companies and i think that is good for
the industry that there are more than
one
big company you know trying to develop
their